I think Cassie Lang is like that she's
just trying to figure out how to be a
good person and you know making a lot of
mistakes she's kind of a mess
tonight such a special night celebrating
and honoring women why is it important
for you to take time out of your busy
schedule to be here and celebrate women
my busy schedule if you are I just think
it's important to build a community of
actors because I want to be able to call
up a girl and be like hey you want to do
this movie with me I think we could do
something really great together have you
done that is there a name that comes to
mind yeah yeah all the time I'm trying
to get my girls from blockers together
getting in Geraldine which we did Gideon
I did Society together you know they're
always the first people I think of you
just want to build that Community that's
how you get great work great work yes
that's how you do it you build a
relationship and
that's what I'm trying to do I've been
doing this too long I have too many good
friends like I want to work with my
friends I love it and I love that you
pay it forward and that you make space
at your table for everybody else it's so
important you know that happened for me
you know well it happened that that's
how you know Reese Witherspoon is like
that Paul Rudd I just worked with on
Ant-Man people still need help that
that's why we made this
[Music]
like a satellite for deep space but
Quanah he's Ant-Man and he made space
for for me to try things and you don't
have to be like that but the greatest
people really are like that you know you
read headlines about Paul Rudd and it's
just like the nicest man in the world
the nicest man in the world what is your
nicest Paul Rudd experience been like
has there been like a moment where
you're like I can't believe you're real
every day really every day he did
something that was like I can't believe
you actually can do this Paul but uh
to hold back and I think that's the
greatest blessing because then I just
tried everything on set every day I
tried jokes maybe they were funny maybe
they weren't and you know that's all you
can that's all you can ask for for sure
you know you broke the internet with the
Ant-Man trailer the other day I did not
oh for sure my goodness top story
so I didn't even know that it was like
dropping and then I landed and my phone
was blowing up it was like my birthday
oh my God you don't even know when your
trailer is coming out come on no I I
wasn't sure I was hopeful I I had heard
it was coming up let me reassure you
everyone is so beyond excited I know you
can't say much but what are you most
excited for fans to learn or discover
with this iteration of Ant-Man
you know dream big or small what does
that mean ant-man's small or big you
don't know that's all I'm gonna say can
you tease like one moment in the movie
that you're just so excited to give to
the fans
no I can't I'm really excited to be in
the movie though now at least I can say
I'm in the movie yes and I'm really
honored to play Kathy Lang and I hope um
I hope people love it I went to the
Black Panther Premiere it was insane it
was so great to be there the excitement
was real to be a part of the family
that's what I'm talking about Community
women in film like Marvel is a big
family and I felt really inspired to be
a part of this universe playing Cassie
what part of Catherine were you most
excited to put on your spin of Cassie
that I'm really not perfect and I'm
super impatient and I want to be a hero
but I have no idea what I'm doing and I
think Cassie Lang is like that she's
just trying to figure out how to be a
good person and you know making a lot of
mistakes
she's kind of a mess really yeah and so
am I
are we gonna see that messiness in
Ant-Man you're definitely gonna see some
some of that oh my good heart okay my
final question I'll stop torturing you
can you describe this new Ant-Man film
in three adjectives
funny epic
beautiful like the world is beautiful
and one more word is Kang that's it yeah
[Music]